a flavor-packed green papaya salad this
is a great salad to serve at a party
it's delicious and robust enough to last
the whole evening without wilting
first off these are a little dried
shrimp you can buy them anywhere
they smell almost sort of the seabed
into the pest and water for this salad
inspired by my travels across Thailand
I'm starting by making a wonderfully
spicy paste a little salt in there in
break them up this place is like a
stable ingredient in Thailand that's
what we're looking for almost
powder right next just one clove of
garlic
slice up the garlic
and get that into the pest and water
bird's eye chili incredibly hot powerful
but wow it does give an amazing kick to
the paste
in to the mix now a couple tablespoons
of brown caster sugar
that softens the blow with a chili and
then just to get that nice sour taste a
little bit of hot water into this
Tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet paste one tablespoon in
fish sauce now it's got that almost sort
of pickly smell slightly salty but the
flavor is intense two tablespoons and
bring that together
and give it a really good mix
some lime juice
in half Another Touch of sort of
tartness
the pace is nice and thick and fragrant
but it's got the heat the sourness the
tartness
incredible
Green Papaya stand it up give it a
little peel you can find Green Papaya
and local Asian shops and bigger
supermarkets and as it doesn't wield
like more delicate Veg it's perfect for
robo salads like this not a great hit
no
that's what I want these thin slivers
next a nice rich
sweet banana shallot
[Music]
nice
some carrot
Cara gives it another texture
now nipple that and mix it
[Music]
finish that off with Thai Basil and
fresh coriander
Thai Basil is a much more fragrant basil
it's stronger and it's slightly thicker
as well
like papaya and Tamarind paste you can
get Thai Basil in good supermarkets and
independent Asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping pan on
and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
indigo
roll them around the pan
gas off and just take them out
now for the exciting Palm I'm going to
dress the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
[Music]
and finally a nice General sprinkling
roasted nuts
and that is one delicious very fragrant
very robust
green papaya salad so easy to make and
guaranteed not to go limp a perfect
party salad and with such incredible
colors textures and bold exciting
flavors it's sure to grab your guest
attention for fuss-free salad dressings
simply add the ingredients into a Jam
Jar screw the lid on tightly and Shake
to combine in seconds there's no need to
wash up a whisk and the jar is ready
made to store any leftovers
when you're putting together a feast for
the family or friends it's great to have
some bulletproof salads in your cooking
repertoire here are three more of my
favorites to set you up
first my delicious chopped salad
foreign
[Music]
and add to the Bowl
along with chopped red pepper and finely
dye shallots
next slice salami into strips
and add follow with nutty chickpeas
and smooth Eden cheese cut into
matchsticks building up different tastes
textures and flavors as you go next add
chicory for a deliciously bitter bite
then chop crisp romaine lettuce
ad for the dressing finely chopped
garlic
add Cherry vinegar a shake or spicy
Worcestershire sauce cast the sugar
and olive oil
then simply whisk
pour the dressing over the salad and mix
so that everything is Thoroughly coated
finally sprinkle with dried oregano for
an aromatic finish a salad so easy if
you can chop you can make it with such
delicious results it has to be tasted to
be believed
[Music]
my next simple salad that's perfect for
a party is green bean salad with mustard
dressing
[Music]
for the dressing wrap a whole bulb of
garlic in foil and roast it in a hot
oven
next add top and tail green beans to
salted boiling water
and cook for just a couple of minutes
this is called blanching and keeps the
beans deliciously crunchy
strain the beans
and refreshing cold water this stops the
cooking process so that stay crisp and
green
[Music]
next remove your garlic from the oven
[Music]
cut off the head
and squeeze out all the Glorious garlic
which has gone creamy mellow and divine
in the oven
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of Dijon mustard
sweet runny honey
season
and pouring a good lug of olive oil then
whisk
add the crunchy blanched green beans
on top with toasted almonds for a lovely
nutty note and crunchy texture
mix well
and serve
Heavenly mustard vinaigrette with a hit
of mellow roast garlic stunning green
beans dressed to perfection
[Music]
my next salad that's great for any big
bash is roasted red pepper lentil and
Herb salad
[Music]
foreign
lentils to vegetable stock
along with a bay leaf and boil for 15
minutes
prelentals are perfect for sellers they
have a great meaty flavor and a
delicious bite for texture
next chop sweet red peppers and place on
a baking tray
along with diced courgette
drizzle over olive oil
season
and roast in a hot oven
foreign
to assemble the salad place the drain
lentils in a large bowl
then add olive oil
[Music]
and chop some blushed tomatoes
take the roasted red peppers and
courgettes from the oven and add
along with chopped avocado as its
delicious creamy flesh give this salad a
lovely contrast
[Music]
season then for a big Herby hit Top a
handful of chives and basil and add
squeeze over lemon juice and mix
earthy aromatic and packed full of
goodness absolutely stunning serve with
roasted meats and fish or perfect eaten
just by itself
foreign